eine Familie machte Deutschland
mobil am Anfang des 20 Jahrhunderts
schufen die Opels das erste Volksauto
damit wurde aus einem Luxusgut ein
alltägliches
Fortbewegungsmittel fünf Brüder
revolutionierten mit dieser Idee das
Land wenn ein Opel was machen möchte
dann macht das auch und setzt dann auch
alles dran und durch dass er sein Ziel
erreicht
für ihre Ziele setzten sie auch schon
mal ihr Leben aufs
Spiel sie erschufen das größte deutsche
Autowerk ihrer
Zeit und veränderten damit die
Gesellschaft das Werk machte sie reich
und ermöglichte ihnen ein Leben auf der
Überholspur
[Musik]
11 märz
1964 der Julia Pass in der
Schweiz der Tag der die Familie Opel für
immer verändern
wird es ist ausgerechnet ein Unfall mit
einem Auto an dem die Familie zu
zerbrechen droht das Automobil hatte die
Familie einst reich gemacht und wurde
zugleich ihr
Fluch die
Opels der großen Familie gelang in
kurzer Zeit ein märchenhafter Aufstieg
mit ihren Ideen hat sie das Leben der
Deutschen für immer
verändert der bekannteste Spross der
Familie war Gunther
Sachs die Opels zählten zu den neun
reichsten Familien Deutschlands doch ihr
Reichtum und Erfolg iten die Familie
Fritz von Opel hätte die Firma einst
führen sollen doch er stand in einem
Konkurrenzkampf mit seinem Cousin Georg
von Opel der Wettstreit hatte Folgen für
die Familie und das Werk zwei starke
Jungs fast gleich alt halbe Generation
verschoben 99
1912 aber zwei Typen da geht's natürlich
auch drum wer ist der bessere wer hat
mehr Glück und da haben sie sich in ganz
vielen Dingen
gemessen die Opelwerke in Rüsselsheim
noch heute steht vor dem Haupteingang
die Büste von Adam Opel nach ihm wurde
das Werk
benannt doch Adam Opel hat nie ein
einziges Auto gebaut
Ende des 19 Jahrhunderts macht er sich
als erfolgreicher Unternehmer einen
Namen er baut
Nähmaschinen und
[Musik]
Fahrräder Adam Opel hat fünf Söhne und
die Träumen heimlich von etwas anderem
etwas aufregenderem
schnellerem
1885 hat im nahen Mannheim Karl Benz das
Automobil erfunden und es ist Wilhelm
der seinen Vater bekniet dass Opel auch
Autos bauen soll doch Adam Opel will
nicht diese stinkkutschen aus denen wird
nie mehr als Spielzeug für Millionäre
das erste Auto das cararl Benz verkauft
hat ging dann einen Mann der
anschließend nachgewiesenermaßen in der
Irrenanstalt ändete und die ganzen Leute
drumum haben gesagt ja klar sowas kann
nur ein Irrer kaufen so war es am Anfang
doch dann erilt die Familie 1895 ein
Schicksalsschlag Adam Opel stirbt an
tyfus er wird nur 59 Jahre
alt durch den Tod des Vaters wird der
Weg frei für Wilhelm den
Sohn
1899 bauen die Opels ihren ersten Wagen
sie achten auf höchsten Komfort und ein
ausgefalltes
Sicherheitskonzept der Wagen besitzt
sogar ein
Seitenlicht doch die Opels müssen viel
investieren damals ist Autobau
Handarbeit jedes Auto ist ein Unikat ein
Kunstwerk Autos bauen sie so im Jahr das
Auto ist nur ein Spielzeug für reiche
Leute die Produktion frisst die
Ersparnisse der Familie auf die Firma
hängt an einem seidenen Faden bei den
Opels war es oft auch fortünen was
mitgeschwingt hat es nicht immer nur
Fleiß und Talent sondern
auch besonders bei den Opels war es viel
Glück was zu dem Gesamterfolg
beitrug mit Autorennen versuchen die
Opels Ihr Produkt bekannt zu machen es
ist ein wagalsiges Unterfangen denn die
Rennen gehen nicht selten tödlich
aus doch sie locken Zuschauer und damit
mögliche Kundschaft 1907 kommt sogar der
Kaiser zu einem internationalen Rennen
und die Opels erreichen als erstes
deutsches Team das
Ziel der Kaiser ist begeistert und
übergibt den
Siegerpokal
aber nicht nur das Seine Majestät wollen
jetzt auch einen
Opel das war noch ein verünftiger Kaiser
der hat gewusst gewusst was gut ist
nicht immer aber wenigens da gewusst was
gut ist Wilhelm Opel ist jetzt
Hoflieferant erträgt die kaiserliche
Uniform unermüdlich treibt er nun seine
Firma an er will mehr
erreichen seinen Ehrgeiz gibt er weiter
an seine Kinder an Tochter Elinor und
vor allem an Sohn Fritz ihm impft er ein
was es heißt ein Opel zu sein die
opelmanier ist Dinge bis nach Ende zu
bringen und die wollen Sieger sein die
wollen die ersten sein das gilt nicht
dass die die zweiten sind mehr schneller
höher dieser Rausch das ist für mich das
eigentliche was die Familie hochgebracht
hat wie ein Komet sozusagen dass sie in
kurzer Zeit so viel erreichen
konnten doch der Aufstieg wird je
gestoppt der Erste Weltkrieg trifft die
Firma schwer die Arbeiter müssen an die
Front die Produktion in Rüsselsheim kann
nur mit Frauen und Kriegsgefangenen
aufrechtterhalten werden und die Familie
trifft das Schicksal
hart Ludwig Opel derste Bruder von
Wilhelm fällt an der
[Musik]
Front da ist es nur ein schwacher Trost
für die Familie dass die Opels für ihre
Pionierarbeit für das Automobil ein Jahr
später geadelt werden die Brüder gehen
schwierigen Zeiten entgegen der Krieg
geht verloren aufgrund der Inflation
kommt die Produktion nahezu zum Erliegen
niemand mehr kann sich die teuren Autos
leisten die OP sind verzweifelt sie
müssen etwas ändern radikal und sie sind
dazu
bereit
Risiko spielt eine sehr große Rolle
und das haben meine Vorfahren auch immer
bewiesen also die haben ja kein Risiko
gescheut neue Dinge
auszuprobieren um die Firma zu retten
kommen die Opels auf eine einfache wie
geniale Idee sie produzieren keine
Luxusautos mehr nun wollen sie einen
kostengünstigen in Kleinwagen bauen und
entwickeln einen Prototypen einen
Zweisitzer mit bootshck der wegen seiner
grünen Lackierung auch Laubfrosch
genannt wird doch dann der Skandal
Citroen hatte bereits vorher einen Wagen
gebaut der exakt genauso aussah der
wurde Zitrone genannt weil er gelb
lackiert war die Franzosen werfen nun
Opel vor sie hätten unerlaubt kopiert
und strengen einen Prozess an vor dem
Reich Kammergericht in Berlin kommt es
zu einem erbitterten Streit die
Franzosen sind außer sich war der Opel
laubfrasch ein
Plagiat in vielen Punkten
ja das weiß man mittlerweile auch ist
man mittlerweile auch bei Opel selbst
bereit zuzugeben also Tante von mir die
Therese Weber eine sehr resolute Dame
die wohnte also auch da in der Nähe im
Mönchhof und die hat immer erzählt i
mein Bruder der anno und ich wir haben
auf Werksgelände immer gespielt und wir
haben doch genau gewusst wo der zitre
versteckt ist das Gericht entscheidet
kein Plagiat der sititroen sei gelb und
der Opel grün lackiert damit wäre jede
Verwechslungsgefahr
ausgeschlossen nur wenige Jahre nach dem
verlorenen Krieg herrscht in der
deutschen Justiz noch keine Franzosen
freundliche Stimmung im Volksmund
entsteht daraus der Spruch das gleiche
in grün der bald im ganzen deutschen
Reich zur Redewendung
wird Glück für Wilhelm von Opel er kann
jetzt den Laubfrosch produzieren um ihn
aber so billig wie möglich zu Bauen
setzt Wilhelm auf eine völlig neuartige
Methode die Idee kam aus Amerika Willem
war drüben und hat gesehen dass flüand
Produktion dort gemacht wird und Amerika
war damals schon fortschrittlich in der
Produktion und und da hat man
hingeschaut und die Söhne haben sich das
mal durchgerechnet und haben gesehen
dass das ein großen Vorteil bringen
würde und waren die ersten die das dann
in Deutschland umgesetzt haben mit
großem
Erfolg 1924 führt Opel als erstes Werk
in Deutschland die fliebandarbeit ein
Wilhelm revolutioniert damit das
Arbeitsleben der deutschen die
Produktivität wird gewissermaßen
erzwungen im Takt des Fließbandes
1924 gab es noch Startprobleme es gab
natürlich dann auch die Panne dass man
nicht bedacht hat dass das menschliche
Bedürfnis die Menschen manchmal vom
Arbeitsplatz abruft die Tätigkeit wird
auf wenige Handgriffe
reduziert schon 1924 warnen Kritiker vor
Entfremdung und Abstumpfung der Arbeiter
heute sehen die Opels die damalige
Einführung des fliesbandes zwiespeltig
gab eine ganz andere Denkweise man war
eben
Bandarbeiter man war eben nicht mehr der
Automobilbauer das kann man auch g
sichicht der Leute kann man es erkennen
wenn die fotografiert werden das
selbstbewusste ist nicht mehr so
vorhanden wie das vorher
war aus meiner Sicht hat das flieband
natürlich nur Vorteile gebracht die
Arbeitsabläufe wurden wesentlich
schneller das Auto konn schneller fertig
gestellt werden und das war der
Durchbruch günstig produzieren zu können
und das Automobil für die breite
Bevölkerung zur Verfügung stellen zu
können die Opels legen den Grundstein
für die
Massenmobilität die Pferde haben
ausgedient alles ändert sich Tankstellen
entstehen Straßen werden gebaut immer
größere Entfernungen können zurückgelegt
werden
das Leben der Menschen verändert
sich die Mobilität hat ich glaube in den
in den
Hirnen dramatische Veränderungen
hervorgerufen weil sind ja alles Wünsche
das sind ja alles Träume die früher
nicht existent waren weil sie nicht
erfüllbar waren und ich glaube das ist
eines der großen gehimne des Automobils
und das ist die Verführbarkeit des
Automobils dass es in der Lage ist
Träume zu realisieren dass diese Träume
mit Albträumen mittlerweile teilweise
verbunden sind ist die
Kehrseite es ist eine Revolution die von
Opel angestoßen wurde das Werk ist Mitte
der 20er Jahre die größte und modernste
deutsche
Automobilfabrik Wilhelm von Opel will
seine neue Macht sichern seine Tochter
Elinor wird mit nur 17 Jahren
verheiratet mit dem industriellen Sohn
Willie Sachs es ist eine Zweckehe die
Sachs produzieren Kugellager und die
kann Wilhelm gut gebrauchen für das Werk
das einmal sein Sohn Fritz übernehmen
möchte Fritz von Opel träumt davon bald
die Firma zu führen doch der
Erwartungsdruck des Vaters lastet schwer
auf ihm er war nach außen hin war er
schon stark nach innen das bekam man
nicht so mit war er unsicher sensibel
hat sich gerne
in Gedichte schreibend und lesend
hinein versponnen war zweifelnder als
man denkt weil er nach außen hin ein
tolles auftreten hatte der Sportsmann
der der
Charmeur Fritz von Opel fährt wie sein
Vater früher Rennen und die sehr
erfolgreich doch es langt nicht
automatisch die Nummer ein in der
Nachfolge zu sein denn er hat ein
Konkurrenten seinen cousern Georg von
Opel auch Georg ist sportlich zu dem
technisch begabt und
ehgeizig schon früh arbeitet er in der
Firma mit 16 ist er noch zu jung und zu
verspielt um sich direkt für die
Nachfolge zu
empfehlen trotzdem bleibt eine
Konkurrenz für seinen Cousin Fritz der
weiß nur der erste zählt bei den Opels
und er will erster bleiben und das
vermag wahrscheinlich auch so die
gewisse Risikobereitschaft bei Fritz von
Opel gewckt zu haben dass man halt schon
auch versucht hat innerhalb der Familie
innerhalb dieses engsten Kreises
herauszustechen und was besonderes zu
leisten Fritz von Opel führt öffentlich
riskante Kunststücke vor er will zeigen
dass er in der Lage ist aus einem
fahrenden Motorboot in ein Flugzeug
umzusteigen
am 23 mai 1928 präsentiert er in Berlin
eine
Sensation ein Raketenauto das mit 120 kg
Dynamit angetrieben wird er will einen
Geschwindigkeitsrekord aufstellen und
der schnellste Mann der Welt
sein
von 0 auf 100 in 8 Sekunden
238 Stunden kilomet
[Musik]
schnell
also dass er jedes Mal mit seinem Leben
spielte mit 120 kg Sprengstoff unter
sich das ist höchstes Risiko wo man
eigentlich sagen müsste grenzwertig fast
wahnsinnig doch Fritz macht weiter im
Sommer 1928 installiert er bei einem
weiteren Test
375 kg Sprengstoff er will aber zunächst
einen unbemannten Versuch starten und
steigt nicht ein
das rettet ihm das
Leben trotzdem will Fritz von Opel
weiter
experimentieren für das Werk in
Rüsselsheim hat das Verhalten des jungen
Opel dramatische
Auswirkungen Wilhelm von Opel trifft
eine wichtige Entscheidung er will sein
Lebenswerk verkaufen bisher wurden immer
nur wirtschaftliche Gründe für diesen
Schritt vermutet zum ersten Mal spricht
die Familie über den eigentlichen Grund
es war kein Nachfolger da eben nur den
Fritz den Fritz von Opel und na ja
können wir das dem das Zutrauen einem
der mit Raketen fliegt und mit Raketen
fährt und der alles mögliche macht
können wir dem dieses große Werk
übergeben es war sicherlich so dass
willlhelm von Opel nicht überzeugt war
von den Fähigkeiten seines Sohnes
äh seines halssprecherischen Sohnes
jetzt in diesem Sinne im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes äh und aus diesem Grund auch
sich überlegt die Firma zu
verkaufen der Verkauf hat Auswirkungen
auf das weitere Leben des Sohnes der vom
Vater übergangen wird
für Fritz von Opel war der Verkauf der
Firma ein sehr großer Schlag ja
1929 geschah das sehr sehr schnell ohne
dass er wirklich ein zutun hatte oder
überhaupt davon
wusste dass dort plötzlich seine
Lebensaufgabe weg war hat ihn sicherlich
erbittert und hat ihn für sein Leben
stark
gebrochen nach schweigt sich die Familie
damals über den wahren Grund des
Verkaufs aus die deutsche Öffentlichkeit
ist fassungslos für sie ist es
vaterlandsverrat denn das Werk wird an
Amerikaner
verkauft der neue Herr aus Detroit
Alfred slone der Manager von General
mortors er will den deutschen Automarkt
erobern doch die öffentliche Stimmung
ist gegen ihn er ist
Ausländer um der Bevölkerung deutsche
Kontinuität vorzutäuschen wird der
greise Wilhelm von Opel als
Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender
installiert es ist eine schwere Aufgabe
denn in Deutschland haben die Nazis die
Macht übernommen und wollen die
Wirtschaft für ihre Zwecke
[Musik]
einspannen Wilhelm soll auch bei den für
Vertrauen Sorgen denn die haben Großes
vor mit der
Automobilindustrie aus der allmlichen
Änderung der Einstellung des deutschen
Volkes dem Kraftwagen gegenüber entstand
ein steigendes Interesse an all dem was
mit dem Kraftwagen und der Motorisierung
zusammenhängt das deutsche Volk ist
deshalb heute nicht nur in seiner
Gesetzgebung sondern auch in sein
Gesamteinstellung kraftwagenfundlich
geworden Hitler fordert den volksw Wagen
auf der Berliner Autoschau 1936 will er
die Entscheidung treffen wer ihn bauen
soll opel hat einen hartnäckigen
Konkurrenten Ferdinand Porsche und
Hitler misstraut den Amerikanern Wilhelm
von Opel soll es richten und den Auftrag
sichern er begrüßte dann aber den Adolf
Hitler mit Heil Hitler Herr Hitler gab
ihm sogar die Hand wie bürgerlich ein
Fehler Hitler hasst es wenn man ihn mit
Namen anspricht er will mein Führer
genannt werden eisiges Schweigen am Opel
standand Hitler kocht innerlich vor Wut
nach einer Minute geht er wieder ohne
das Auto näher betrachtet zu haben
wenige Tage später gibt er Ferdinand
Porsche den Auftrag für den
Volkswagen und er lässt sich mit dem
Führer feiern
Opel geht ein millioneneschäft verloren
Wilhelm von Opel hat es verbockt ja was
heißt verbockt hätte gesagt mein Führer
Unheil Hitler und ich B untertänigst ihr
hoffentlich künftiger lierant was wir
wird wir dann heute sagen er hat also
mit Sicherheit nicht bewusst
versucht provokant zu
sein ich denke er hat einfach da nicht
drüber nachgedacht er hat versucht sich
gut zu benehmen und hat aber halt
vollkommen falsch
gemacht Wilhelms Schwiegersohn Willie
sach zeigt wie man es richtig macht auch
der präsentiert dem Führer seine
neuesten
Produkte kann gut mit den führenden
Nazis besonders gut mit Heinrich Himmler
beide treffen sich wiederholt auch
privat als Willi Sachs das Ehepaar
himler einladen will kommt es zu einem
ikla mit seiner Ehefrau
[Musik]
Ellinor ja sie mochte alle Leute die
irgendwo der Partei nah waren nicht
besonders und sicherlich auch nicht die
Führungskräfte und
wie das ihr pa himler kommen sollte
sagte sie diese Putzfrau kommt mir nicht
ins Haus die Ehe zerbricht bald darauf
elenor flüchtet mit ihren Söhnen Ernst
Wilhelm und Gunter Sachs in die
Schweiz der erzohnte Gatte bittet seinen
Freund himler um Hilfe zusammen mit
Reinhard Heidrich legt der SS-Führer
Dossiers über Ellinor an er lässt sie
beobachten um seinem Freund wie die
Sachs zu helfen denn die SS hat einen
perfiden Plan sie will die Kinder
entführen der kleine Gunter Sachs soll
heim ins Reich gebracht
werden Himmler und Heidrich schicken
vier SS-Männer in die
Schweiz sie bringen die Kinder zunächst
in ihre Gewalt doch die Schweizer
Polizei kann sie wieder befreien was dem
kleinen Gunter Sachs bleibt ist
Angst mein Vater hatte ganz klar
Erinnerungen dass eben quasi zu Hause
bleiben sollten und nicht mehr raus
sollten und mit niemandem sprechen und
so weiter also das weiß ich das hat er
noch hat er noch ganz klar gesagt bis
zum Kriegsende 45 fürchten sie sich vor
weiteren Attacken der SS es ist eine
klaustrophobische Erfahrung die den
Heranwachsenden Gunter Sachs für sein
Leben prägt mein Vater war ein starker
Individualist und er hatte auch eine
charakterlichische Großzügigkeit die
auch dort dorthining leben und leben
lassen so wie er auch leben wollte ja
also diesen großen Drang irgendwo zur
Freiheit nur 30 Jahre bauten die Opels
Autos in Rüsselsheim das Werk veränderte
Deutschland aber das Werk veränderte
auch die
Familie
1948 stirbt Wilhelm von Opel er hatte
das Werk aufgebaut und
verkauft bestattet wird er im
opelmausoleum in Rüsselsheim das direkt
am Werk
steht der Verkauf der Firma hatte die
Familie reich gemacht und stellte sie
jetzt vor neue
Herausforderungen das fehlte das die
Aufgabe das Auto war weg stattdessen war
Geld da und man musste selbst anfangen
ob als Elternteil oder als begünstigtes
Kind was daraus zu machen das ja
furchtbar schwer wenn man das nicht
gelernt hat wenn man schon heiß gebadet
aufgewachsen ist und
dann was Neues erfinden muss ist
schwierig die Familie ist groß und jeder
wählt einen anderen Weg Gunter Sachs der
sich immer auch als Opel empfindet und
sich zeitweise Gunter Sachs von Opel
nennt nutzt den Reichtum auf sein Art
und wird der erste bekannte deutsche
Playboy er hatte ja eine
unwahrscheinliche aus eine Aura möchte
man fast sagen die man gespürt hat wenn
man in seiner Nähe war das war etwas
fast überirdisches es sprachen wir von
Freunden sie sind aber glaube ich auch
bekannt dass sie Freundinnen mehr oder
weniger als ihr hob
betrachten ich glaube jeder jungeselle
in meinem Alter hat ein bisschen dieses
Hobby nur hat er nicht gleich das Pech
dass das jedes mal in der Zeitung steht
Gunter Sachs zeigt der Welt einen völlig
neuen Typus des deutschen er prägt das
Lebensgefühl einer ganzen
Generation er ist das Gegenteil des
langweiligen lustfeindlichen und
autoritätshürigen Spießers und gerade
die Franzosen lernen nur wenige Jahre
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg das deutsche
auch anders sein
können er war dann ein toller
Botschafter für Deutschland ohne es zu
wollen ja aber er wurde zu dem und hatte
dann natürlich ein
Art zu leben wovon vielen Leuten viel
Leute davon
träumten wie alle in der Familie Opel
ist guntersachs ein begeisterter
Sportler in St Moritz widmet er sich
seiner Leidenschaft dem
Wintersport
dort trifft er auch seine Opel
Verwandtschaft wie seinen Onkel Georg
Georg von Opel war 17 Jahre alt als das
Werk 1929 verkauft
wurde als Opel fühlt er sich der
Tradition jedoch verpflichtet und
gründet ein Autohaus wenn er die Opel
Autos schon nicht bauen kann dann will
er sie zumindest
verkaufen das Geschäft ist sehr
erfolgreich da die Opel Autos in den
50er Jahren einen sehr guten Ruf haben
aber der Erfolg füllt ihn nicht aus er
ist einsam wenn er abends nach Hause
kommt wartet niemand auf
ihn
1938 hatte er zwar geheiratet doch die
Ehe ist in den 50er Jahren bereits
gescheitert er sucht Herausforderungen
und reist viel in Ostafrika besteigt er
den
kidimanjaro
er verliebt sich in das Land die
Menschen und die Tiere und kommt auf
eine
Idee dann kann wir das Bedürfnis eben
wilde Tiere dann auch im
Gehege zu halten und na ja es muss da
schon was besonderes sein und das war
eben dann die Elefanten und dann kom
Anfang 50er Jahre dann die ersten drei
ersten Z oder drei Elefanten in Kronberg
an zum Erstaunen aller Kronberger und
Königsteiner eine Sensation im Taunus
der erste
elefantentransport Georg hält die Tiere
direkt neben seinem Wohnhaus sehr zur
Freude der Nachbarn und seiner Söhne
Heinz und
Carlo
immer mehr Tiere kommen
[Musik]
hinzu der einzige privatz Deutschlands
entsteht doch glücklich ist Georg von
Opel nicht er war ein stark schwacher
Typ schwach vielleicht eben in dieser
privaten familiären Seite ich glaube das
ist ganz schwierig in der dritten
Generation aus so einer Familie
herauszukommen sich zu orientieren was
mache ich zu glauben man ist auf der
Schiene und dann privat auch noch Glück
zu haben das also er war ein ständig
Suchender Mensch
der große Bedürfnisse an Familiensinn
und Wärme Harmonie
hatte doch dann erfüllt sich sein
sehnlichster Wunsch
1957 heiratet er Eugenia eine 39-jährige
Kolumbianerin
sie teilt seine Vorliebe für exotische
Tiere und sie liebt seinen
[Musik]
Humor das war wohl eine Liebesbeziehung
eine Liebesheirat und offensichtlich
eine sehr glückliche ze it weil sie in
der Zeit meinem Großvater viel Ruhe
brachte er hat zu sich gefunden
allerdings Eugenia Eugenia wie man sagt
aus Kolumbien hatte eine Schwester die
wiederum mit dem großen Antipoden Fritz
ja liiert
war Fritz von Opel und seine Frau emita
die Schwester von
Eugenia zwar hatte Georg seine Frau über
Fritz kennengelernt doch das versöhnte
die beiden Cousins auch nicht
wieder Fritz von Opel hat den Verkauf
der Firma nie verkraftet das hat ihn
verändert er wurde depressiv und
unberechenbar sein Umfeld fürchtete
seine cholerischen Anfälle es wurde sehr
viel in der Familie über ihn gesprochen
und es gab dort in der Familie oft
größere quirelen ja
die mit Fritz zu tun hatten ich weiß do
dass er ein
übermäßig streng mit seinen Kindern
waren die fast regelrecht darunter l und
eine richtige Angst hatten ja
vor dem vor ihrem Vater Fritz hat zwei
Kinder Ricky und Christina genannt Putzi
vor allem die kleine Tochter leidet
unter ihrem Vater er stellt das
zweijährige Kind minutenl unter die
eiskalte Dusche weil sie keinen
Seemannsknoten hinbekommt sperrt er sie
für Stunden in die Kajüte seiner Yacht
ein
allein manchmal verprügelt er seine
Tochter so sehr dass die Schläge
tagelang mit Puder behandelt werden
müssen er nennt das
Erziehung Liebe bekommt sie nur von
Onkel
[Musik]
Georg
das Mädchen hängt auch sehr an Eugenia
ihrer
Lieblingstante beide geben dem
heranwachsenden Kind halt und machen oft
mit Putzi gemeinsam
Urlaub es ist der märz
1964 als Putzi ihre Tante Eugenia bittet
mit dem Auto in ein besseres Skigebiet
zu fahren wo noch mehr Schnee
liegt irgendwo mit dem Auto hinfahren
das was ihre Vorfahren einst erst
möglich gemacht haben wird Ihnen jetzt
zum
Fluch
Tante Eugenia stirbt Putzi kommt schwer
verletzt ins
Krankenhaus Fritz von Opel eilt sofort
an das Bett seines Kindes und sagt nur
drei
Sätze du bist schuld dass deine Tante
tot ist nur weil du woanders Skifahren
wolltest du hast sie
getötet diese Worte brechen den
Lebenswillen des jungen Mädchens die
Schuldgefühle wird Putz nie los
auch ihr Onkel Georg wird den tragischen
Unfall nie verwinden
oh das war ein enormer Verlust das hat
ihn richtig reingerissen in eine
Depression in in Gräben wo er sich neu
definieren musste wo er sein Bild von
Familie Harmonie Wärme Zärtlichkeit neu
wieder instand setzen musste wollte er
war so jemand der Lehre nicht ertragen
wollte deswegen heiratete er ein drittes
Mal die 30 Jahre jüngere sigrd die Ehe
verläuft nicht glücklich doch sie macht
ihn noch einmal zum
Vater
1968 wird Gregor geboren ich habe leider
gar keine Erinnerung aber da so viele
äh Mitmenschen
ähm mir berichtet haben glaube ich ein
ganz gutes Bild haben zu können von ihm
aber eigene Erinnerung ist mit drei
natürlich auch fast nicht möglich
Georg von Opel findet sein Glück nicht
mehr
1971 nur 7 Jahre nach dem tragischen
Unfall seiner Ex-Frau verunglückt er in
seinem
Auto er hatte ein herzentfakt das ist
die Todesursache als Bild habe ich aber
immer so gerne in Erinnerung dass er
auch am gebrochenen Herzen starb das was
das Leben ebenenso mit sich brachte mit
der ganzen Geschichte von Opel die in
ihm in besonderem Maße verkörpert wurde
als einer der letzten großen Opels die
dann einsam gegen ein Zaun
fuhren im gleichen Jahr stirbt auch
Fritz von Opel der alte Konkurrent von
Georg seine Tochter Putzi hatte da schon
längst mit der Familie
gebrochen es ist schade dass so
ausgegangen ist das hätte nicht sein
müssen denn sie war ein sehr befähigte
und sehr begabte
Frau bei Alkohol und Drogen sucht Putzi
Ersatz für
Geborgenheit ohne Schulabschluss ohne
Beruf aber mit viel Geld und falschen
Freunden sie wird selbstmutter ungewollt
doch das Kind hindert sie nicht am Leben
eines wilden
[Musik]
partygs
in santropé will sie ein unbeschwertes
Luxusleben führen mit sechs Freunden
doch das Paradies wird zur
Hölle im Sommer 77 findet die Polizei in
ihrem Haus 1,8 Tonnen Haschisch im Wert
von 8 Millionen DMark ihre Freunde
hatten die Drogen besorgt Putzi wird
verhaftet
[Musik]
wie die Sache passiert war war ich in
saintropeé auch und ich weiß noch ich
kamn am Morgen in mein übliches Kaffee
wo ich meine Zeitung kaufte und mein
Kaffee trank und die waren ganz erstaunt
dass ich da war weil die haben gedacht
ich wäre auch festgenommen worden ja und
damals war das ganz klar da sind glaube
ich sechs Personen festgenommen worden
aber alle sprachen
nur laff
Opel Putzi steht allein im Fokus und
zahlt einen hohen Preis für Reichtum und
den bekannten Namen ihr Cousin Gunther
sach bleibt an ihrer Seite und will ihr
helfen es kommt zur Verhandlung
1979 wird sie zu 10 Jahren Gefängnis
verurteilt das französische Gericht
wollte ein Exempel statuieren so glaubt
die Familie bis heute wir haben das als
Tragödie gesehen weil
wir wussten dass sie in falsche Kreise
gekommen war und eigentlich nicht die
treibende Kraft
in der Sache war dass sie
nur benutzt wurde und dafür so lange ins
Gefängnis musste wir fanden das
richtig wir fanden das überzogen
ungrecht doch nach dre Jahren wird sie
wegen ihrer kleinen Tochter freigelassen
der französische Staat gibt ihr eine
zweite Chance und die nutzp
[Musik]
sie will ihrer Tochter eine bessere
Kindheit schenken als sie sie selbst
hatte
über die Zeit im Gefängnis schweigt
sie das war schon sehr sehr schlimm für
Sie da hat sie gar nicht rüber sprechen
wollen so schlimm war das für sie das
hat sie wohl D doch weggedrängt auch
ihrer Tochter das hat sie
versteckt jedes Familienmitglied hat
seine Art mit der schicksalhaften
Familiengeschichte umzugehen Gregor von
Opel hat seinen Vater nie richtig
kennengelernt und fühlt sich trotzdem
dessen Erbe
[Musik]
verpflichtet heute lebt er im Haus
seines Vaters im
[Musik]
Taunus was ge von Opel einst anfing das
will der Sohn
weiterführen als er volljährig wurde
übernahm er das Autohaus des
Vaters mir hat das von Anfang an Spaß
gemacht mit dem Auto was zu tun zu haben
und ich habe es als Herausforderung
gesehen und ich wollte das Erbe
weiterführen das war das war meine
Motivation im Zuge der opelkrise
verkaufte er das Autohaus 2006 aus aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen er ist der
letzte Opel der direkt etwas mit Autos
zu tun hatte mit ihm ging eine lange
Tradition zu Ende und es hat nicht so
wie geplant funktioniert und deswegen
kann ich mich im Spiegel schauen und
sagen du hast es versucht
aber das Geschäft
war nicht das was du gedacht hast was es
wäre doch der Vater hat ihm noch etwas
anderes hinterlassen Max das nilpfer
ahchmerz noch heute lebt es direkt am
Haus der Opels zusammen mit 1500
weiteren
Tieren beleidigt ne Gregor von Opel hat
den Tierpark des Vaters zu einem der
erfolgreichsten Zoos Deutschlands
aufgebaut jährlich kommen rund 600.000
Besucher zur Anlage es ist in die
Tradition des Vaters der hier ja ein
ganzes Stück Herzblut reingesteckt hat
und etwas es geschaffen hat
das muss nicht nur halten werden das
muss auch ausgebaut werden einen anderen
Weg ist sein Bruder Carlo gegangen er
hat mit der Tradition der Opels
gebrochen ausgerechnet er der Nachfahrer
der autopioniere ist wieder beim Pferd
gelandet auf seinem Gestüt Peters au
widmet er sich den
Vierbeinern das Pferd zieht er dem Auto
vor ja weil es
lebt man kann mit Pferd erleben man kann
mit Pferd arbeiten kann mit Pferd was
tun ist halt ein
Lebewesen ist irgendwo nur Blech also
auch ganz teurer Wagen ist ja nur Blech
da muss man dran denken wenn man so ein
ja so eine Blech Kiste einsteigt das
Auto allein kann es nicht sein es gibt
ja noch eine andere Welt neben dem Auto
und das war eben dann die Welt mit ein
PS die Welt mit mehreren PS bestimmte
jahrzehntelang das Leben der Opels ihr
Pioniergeist machte sie reich stellte
sie aber auch vor Herausforderungen die
die Familie
zweiten im Mausoleum in Rüsselsheim
liegen alle Opels
vereint der Stammvater Adam Opel wäre es
nach ihm gegangen hätte die Familie nie
ein Auto
gebaut sein Sohn Wilhelm der ein
Imperium aufbaute und das Leben der
Familie veränderte dessen Tochter Elinor
die sich den Nazis verweigerte ihr
Bruder
Fritz und sein ewiger Konkurrent sein
Cousin
Georg die heutigen Opels sind mit dem
Erbe ihreror fren im
reinen es war sicherlich mehr Segen als
Unglück würde ich sagen denn immerhin
sind wir jetzt in der vierten Generation
bin ich meine Kinder sind in der fünften
Generation und fühlen sich noch im
Herzen sehr mit Opel verbunden fühle
mich sogar noch als Opel man ist aus
diesem Humus aus dieser familienerde
aufgewachsen man ist immer vertraut
gewesen mit der ganzen Historie wie ist
das überhaupt dazu gekommen weil es ja
auch ein Teil von einem selbst
ist der Großvater die Großmutter und so
[Musik]
weiter
y